the reason we're together yes we're
together because of that ellen degeneres
is giving major credit to adam levine
revealing he's largely responsible for
why she and wife portia de rossi are
together that's the greatest thing we
won't go into detail because it's
private stuff but i will tell you guys
that i'm technically
the reason
you met porsha well not why i met her
but you're why we're together the reason
you're together yes okay not why you met
her no but i'm definitely the reason
we're together yes we're together
because of that they don't give us the
play-by-play as for how adam was
involved but they do tell us all about
their years-long friendship first of all
i love you you know that but this is
your 26th time on the show and you were
here almost every single season since
season one we've had you every single
season
the two relive some of their sweetest
moments one of them well it all started
with a sweater i don't know if it was
the second time you were on but i
admired your you had like a cardigan on
was it the second time yeah it was
literally like a blazer no it was a
cardigan because we still have it i i
admired it you know he was here and i
said i love that cardigan he took it off
and gave it to me and we still have it
every once in a while i wear it or
porsche wears it and we're like that's
adam's adam confesses it was a big
gesture for him because he had had quite
a smaller wardrobe at the time before he
became the star he is today by the way
i've become more successful since then
so but back then that was like know big
deal that was a big deal i only owned
like four things i know it was not lost
on me i'm glad you still have it and of
course ellen had the best way to pay
back her friend what i've done in
exchange is i named your firstborn child
it is true that she was i mean like i
kind of like i know that it was
definitely a name that you recommended
and that i brought up to tobiatsi and
she was like didn't get it at first and
then she kind of kind of she warmed up
to it so yeah i mean you really you kind
of did the name ellen came up with dusty
the couple's first daughter was born
back in 2016 and in 2018 they welcomed
their second daughter gio i was kind of
you're born to be a parent i think adam
is such a girl dad he just is so good
with them they love him so much as for
if they have plans to expand their
family adam's wife bahati told et last
year it's not out of the question but
she's hoping to bring a boy into the mix
i'm always like i wonder if we have a
third like what would it be a boy or
girl obviously a healthy baby we don't
care but i always thought i was only
gonna have boys for some reason i
thought i'm gonna only have boys and
then adam came along and we only had
girls and he honestly at this point
keeps telling me he's like i don't think
i would know what to do with a boy like
i was i'm a boy obviously and i was a
teenage boy and he's like i don't know
if i know what to do with that
he's like girls are so much more like
mature and and clean and
i do i'm like ah
i would love a boy
[Music]